you had this iconic role and then you
have taken all of these great chances
like you've really stretched as an actor
and theater and in film you've done this
this really cool work yeah and and one
of the things that's fun is every now
and then the paparazzi catches you when
you're in a new role where you're really
going for it they got I don't know I
think it's a role that you you did in a
film that hasn't come out yet called
guns akimbo yes yes and they got this
picture of you and it looks like you've
lost and I spend like the majority of
the movie that is my costume for like
the first two-thirds of the movie I was
just like running around downtown
Auckland in New Zealand dressed like
that and a thing happens sometimes where
like a photo like that will come out and
people don't know it's from a film no
like so people I I know it like seems
obviously that would be a fictional
situation but some people just go like
he's lost his mind
yeah like saris and it happened when I
was doing I did a short cameo in in
train record you know I was walking a
lot of dogs and a picture of me like
walking 11 dogs came out and people were
like so you a dog yeah
[Laughter]